[Applaudissements]
le festival djaka loupé de retour sur
l'esplanade du parc olympique de
montréal en fin de semaine compétition
de planche à roulettes escalade de blocs
motocross belgium 500 participants
athlètes de haut niveau des
professionnels de l'industrie des
amateurs d'adrénaline des curieux
également c'est un festival qui connaît
beaucoup de succès et s'est même concept
qui s'exporte même à l'extérieur du
canada avec nous ce soir michael
desforges qui est le président fondateur
de jackalope et pdg de l'agencé tribu on
le retrouve à l'esplanade d'ailleurs du
temps frénétique bonsoir
ça va ça va bien merci expliquer d'où ce
qui déjà 15
ans que le jackalope est le plus grand
festival
au canada on y retrouve les
constructions kemball
international on
brade
du bmx bref un événement de grande
envergure à billets gratuits pour les 10
ans et moins volé quelques images à
l'écran et c'est aujourd'hui ce week-end
on célèbre jimmy miller tabak
justement quand claire marchionne on est
en train d'exporter
et là il ya beaucoup de gens qui partent
c'est pas ça ya beaucoup de gens qui
assistent à votre événement
dans l'événement qui gagne en popularité
vous savez l'espoir qui ont été
marginalisés par
les jeux de los angele
dans dix ans dans dix ans on se
dit
c'est par là sont en croissance et on le
ressent 10 et la dent dans ce qu on
appelle ça des sports d'action ce que
vous présentez vous
l'événement que vous faites regroupe une
série de sports d'action
exact donc un rassemblement de
communautés différentes
pour les renault mais encore une fois on
à la communauté du scribe horde de l'
escalade du breakdance
belgique
motocross bmx bref des gens que vous
retrouverez nulle part ailleurs tous au
même endroit jarrier de comme ça au
canada et puis c'est pour ça justement
une depuis dix ans nous on veut donner
une vitrine pour ces passionnés et de la
culture qui les représente le break
dance dont vous parlez deviendra même
une discipline sportive aux jeux
olympiques de paris en 2024 les jeux
olympiques qui font qu'ils font de la
place maintenant la planche à roulettes
l'escaladent le cirque donc ce que vous
présentez aujourd'hui à peu près tous se
retrouvent vous êtes en train de se
retrouver aux jeux olympiques
exactement dans l'écran plusieurs images
de différentes disciplines on les
représente dans la plupart on n'a pas de
charge parce qu'on est à montréal au
parc critique mais blague à part on
expliqué c'est une forme de sessions de
surf dans notre camp ce papa de
compétition juste parce que l'état de
choisy ne cite pas avec les vagues
détails techniques mais en échelle dans
le fond nous on est vraiment comme des
ambassadeurs de toute une année sur les
fonds en actions est-ce que vous avez
créé à montréal donc je comprends que
vous le l'exporter à virgin au bic
depuis votre concert que vous exportés à
l'étranger
exact nous on est des fervents un
croyant qui a un énorme bassin de
talents en création événementielle et en
cage et son expérience à montréal au
québec jackalope existe depuis dix ans
ça a été créé tout petit ça va évoluer
et puis compare d'après midi que toutes
les villes sont en compétition les unes
contre les autres pour les cerveaux les
sièges sociaux le tourisme événementiel
surtout sportif rejoint un gang de
motards économique simulait donc pour
nous après plusieurs rencontres avec
différentes villes canadiennes et
américaines
on a tendu la main à jean hey [ __ ] avec
qui nous avons annoncé un partenariat de
trois ans qui commence à part le juin 23
dont concret le jackalope virginia beach
celui de montréal demeure mais ont créé
une réplique à prayssas l'ambition c'est
justement faire en europe en asie en
amérique latine et éventuellement bâtir
le cirque du soleil de l'adrénaline le
cirque du soleil de la vie dreno l'insee
quand même d'accord on voit l'image
j'ai lu que les athlètes féminines de
planche à roulettes ont salué votre
décision chez vous dans votre
organisation de leur accorder des
bourses équivalentes aux hommes il ya
déjà plusieurs années qu'est ce qui vous
a motivé à vous assurer de cette parité
de cette égalité
mais c'est un simple constat pour être
un non sens oui on s'est dit on en
europe et une mission et pour cette
mission là qui est supporté les athlètes
masculins et féminins on a besoin
d'avoir une certaine relève on a eu la
chance d'avoir la légende vivante du
skateboard ton erreur quelques années
qui est venu à jackalope pendant deux
ans 2007 2010 8 puis au fil du temps
c'est aujourd'hui on a besoin aussi
d'avoir des athlètes féminines qui campe
bien là où j ai par le passé il n'y
avait pas de l'être féminin gagner des
bourses d'envergure comme en présence
jackalope qui encore pire car seule la
différence
hommes et femmes dans les compétitions
étaient quand même assez sait combien
une bougie suis libre et où on a trente
mille dollars
visiblement donc quinze mille chez les
hommes 15 me tuer femmes c'est pas des
montagnes vont changer la vie et c'est
de quelqu'un mais c'est une bonne tape
dans le dos la première position avec
5000 $ et surtout une visibilité
incroyable qui lui permet de poursuivre
son parcours chez nous on a eu à niglio
qui ai gagné deux fois le jackalope chez
les femmes et éventuellement qui a
représenté
le canada en
cas d'effort je vous ai deux
prise d'un fondateur de jackalope on
vous souhaite une bonne fin de semaine
ça se passe en fin de semaine au stade
olympique merci
merci à vous on vous invite à venir
découvrir sa
bonne semaine
roy pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit